لذلك لدي ثلاث فتيات يذهبن إلى الصف العاشر في
الصف الثامن والصف السادس ، لذا كما
يمكنك أن تتخيل ما سيحدث
هذا الخريف هو الموضوع الأول في
منزلنا ماذا سيحدث مع
مدارس الأكاديمية الأمريكية
لطب الأطفال ، لقد كانوا واضحين جدًا في
هذا الأمر.  يقول إن الأطفال في المدرسة جسديًا
هو مفتاح نموهم ، لكننا نعلم أيضًا
أن أعداد الحالات تستمر في الارتفاع في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ، ولا يزال من غير
الواضح تمامًا مدى قابلية الانتقال ،
خاصة الأطفال الصغار ، نعلم
أنهم أقل عرضة للإصابة بالمرض ولكن ما مدى
احتمالية إصابتهم  للمساهمة في
الانتشار ، نعلم أيضًا على وجه اليقين
أن المدارس ستفعل كل
ما في وسعها لمحاولة الحفاظ على سلامة الأطفال ، لذا
سيبدو الأمر مختلفًا كثيرًا عندما
تصل إلى المدرسة هذا العام
الآن يفعل أي شيء نعرفه عن هذا
الفيروس إنه  لا تحب الأقنعة ،
لذا ستكون مطلوبة في جميع
المدارس ولا تحب المسافة ، لذلك
ترى هنا المكاتب ومنطقة المدرسين التي
تفصل بينها مسافة ستة أقدام تدرك جيدًا أن
لا تستطيع الكثير من المناطق التعليمية
القيام بذلك ، كل المكاتب التي تواجه نفس
الاتجاه إذا كان هناك أي فيروس في
المنطقة التي تريد الذهاب إليها في اتجاه واحد
بدلاً من الاختلاط أيضًا ، فهناك
فكرة التجميع التي تعني أن
نفس الطلاب سيكونون  سويًا طوال اليوم
أقل انتشارًا وأقل اختلاطًا بهذه
الطريقة وأيضًا إذا مرض شخص ما ،
فمن الأسهل الاتصال به تتبع
شيء آخر يجب أن تفكر فيه المدارس
حول محاولة تقليل المناطق التي
يتجمع فيها الأطفال والشيء الآخر
الذي قد تبدأ المدارس بفعله
هو الخروج في الهواء الطلق  الفصول الدراسية أو على الأقل
فتح النوافذ لتحسين
التهوية في الفصول الدراسية الداخلية في
نهاية اليوم ، سيتعين على كل أسرة
النظر في مخاطر
ومكافآت إعادة أطفالهم إلى
المدرسة.
هل يتزايد الفيروس
أم أنه يتناقص ، فقد
يلعب هذا عاملاً في قرارك
واستخدام بقية الصيف أخيرًا
لجعل أطفالك يعتادون على الإرهاق  أقنعة ng
التي سيتعين عليهم القيام بها
وبالطبع غسل أيديهم قدر الإمكان